ladies and gentlemen Lisgar vez you saw
that clip in that clip that was New York
Times reporter Maggie Haberman she's one
of the people you focus on in this
documentary yes why would you focus a
third-rate reporter like Maggie Haven
Maggie is an extraordinary reporter and
journalist she's kind of you know one of
the the backbones of the White House
team reporting on this president
she's a very public face of for the New
York Times and she's also a mom and a
person who works really really hard and
was a person who I think people could
relate to I can't relate to her I'm just
like Donald Trump I've never heard of
Maggie Haberman he doesn't talk to her
apparently never at all have you talked
to her that was a setup phone call
emissary he's never met her what so
let's back up here you embedded with the
New York Times what why would you why
would you want to follow the failing New
York Times I thought it was a good time
to kind of pull back the curtain on how
the sausage is made how you know you
it's incredible you know if you work in
the New York Times you're given so much
information every single day you get
tips if you put them out there they
would be salacious the process by which
they confirm and vet their stories and
before they put them in the newspaper is
pretty incredible so I thought it was
important to see that process now in
watching this process you're watching
them struggle which is one of the
moments that I like with how to cover
the news as it was changing in the Trump
era it was moving faster they're
figuring out ways in which to change
basically fundamentally how the New York
Times works what was that like well what
were you noticing the thing about the I
mean the news cycle is relentless right
and the competition I mean it seems to
matter very very much for the people who
work in the New York Times that they
beat the Washington Post all the time
and I mean really by minutes you know if
like you get your alert on the phone on
your phone and it's it's a New York
Times and they've like then they
Washington Post one comes like two
minutes later imagine them all
high-fiving each other and to you you're
still getting the information you're all
good but it's very meaningful and I you
know I like that because it means they
care about their work but the kind of
the drive and the incessant pressure to
to get out there to be first but also to
be right which is the most important
thing
but that has shifted even the last year
I mean Trump has changed everything oh
gee Trump way to go but but they do feel
this need to to get the news out within
minutes as opposed to within 24 hours
that's right did you notice that
changing the quality of the news I mean
it fundamentally has to well you know
what I think is I mean look everybody
makes mistakes and your times makes
mistakes
you know they generally want to own up
to them and we call them out here all
the time
I know some of them even our mistakes
until we call them up that's right
you've discovered so many mistakes but
in general given the amount of news that
they put out like you know thousands of
stories every week they basically been
getting them right one of my favorite
moments was when you got to watch them
downsize oh okay well that wasn't
exactly downsizing that was reorganizing
I like to think of it as a downside yeah
tell me something I already know
something you already know well one
thing that I found was when these time
journals when we'd go out in the world
with them you know and they'd walk into
a place like CPAC your favorite place
the concern oh so warm and so fun best
style in the world so they lot so you go
to CPAC and your New York Times
journalist you introduce yourself as
someone from The Times and people kind
of react like we're gonna stay away
after five minutes of talking they're
like you're fine I like you and there is
that connection that happens when people
realize that those other people that
they've demonized are just human could
you think I think that is a that is a
good lesson so whatever you could do
stay away the Fourth Estate airs Sundays
all four parts are available now on all
Showtime platforms including on-demand
and streaming Liz Garbus the fight
continued
[Music]